welcome to families episode number two
today we have sponsors
credit karma money and honey
nice nice you want five percent uh
yeah sure why not
um we've got a great show planned today
a really great show
now mom out before i get into the meat
of it i have for you a special
test
last week you learned certain slangs of
the kids these days
including uh so i'm going to give you
three words
and if you can use them properly every
time you use one of them properly
throughout the show i'll give you a
hundred dollars damn i didn't know there
was gonna be a test
so bra moment
is a good moment
well i'll judge it based on your usage
so you can use bra moment no cap or on
god and anytime you use those correctly
i'll give you 100. no cap on god and bro
moment bruh bruh b-r-u-h bra moment yeah
okay and you have to pronunciate it
right bruh so we'll have a ruling every
time you attempt to use it oh no
okay so and then also i want to we're
having a conversation before we started
that i want to touch on
my dad is bragging that he got a
thousand twitter followers but i am not
going to publicly endorse your twitter
dad
if you're still following porn stars
i don't see the connection or lack
thereof
because it's people found my dad's
twitter account
and this isn't like i'm not out here to
humiliate my dad this is something we've
had
several conversations about is that his
whole twitter account people started my
dad was started commenting on all my
tweets like a few years ago and people
obviously found out it was my dad cause
this is gary klein
and um there and then there was posts on
the subreddit like oh get all gary falls
is these crazy porn accounts
really do you know that people can see
your follows right three
uh
porn stars who are all intelligent women
that oh is that all right right and
other things that's like playboy you're
reading it for just the uh
you following it for their their
intelligent political takes right for
their political insights yeah right
right
you're reading the articles
there's articles
okay wait because when you we first
discovered your twitter follows a few
years ago it was like 90 porn so have
you have you called your followings
i i i would disagree with your
accounting methods though okay so you're
saying three ian open up my dad's
twitter
and let's do an inventory right now
all right so ian's gonna do an inventory
of how many porn accounts you're [ __ ]
isn't that a violation of my fifth
amendment right somehow you don't have
to say anything but you're i just it's
important for you to know
that um your followers are public dad i
realize that cause if you're bragging
about you gotta clean your [ __ ] up if
you want more followers i can't endorse
you when you're following all these porn
stars okay again it's gonna be three
and i know i'm the only man in the
entire united states who occasionally
watches porn no one else that it
supports that multi-billion dollar
industry there's a difference between
watching porn
and actively following them on twitter
as a public figure's dad who's bragging
about his twitter accounts
i agree thank you mom i agree
that's shocking you agree what how do
you feel about dad following all this
porn on twitter oh three i well you know
as a woman i understand
that men watch pornography sure i mean
since your father and i have been
married which is
almost 47 years now
that's always been a part of what dad
does what i don't like is the
interaction
you know
there you know that interaction
well you know like he'll write something
or he'll you know whoa what is dad right
i don't know you'll have to ask me i
love you look at that [ __ ] eating grin
on my dad wait what is dad right i mean
i like comments on pornhub yeah i think
you write comments on pornhub
no i do not any comments that i've made
are political in nature on pornhub
accounts yeah i can you know i can name
most of the accounts i follow since i
believe there's only three
he believes any fingers being held up to
help count back ian is certainly taking
inventory
we're waiting for the final uh count
we're doing a recount here
but you know i i don't
uh dismiss the opinions of sex workers
because of their occupation ha smack
smack take that no i think that's a i
agree but i wouldn't i'm not i'm just
i'm questioning the validity of
following them specifically there's
political figures that you can follow
why porno stars
oh don't you think among the 1100
twitter followers i have there are some
political things well hold on let's
let's start
he's got four
how far are you
[Laughter]
and this is after my dad called
you did a calling of the f because we
called you out on this years ago or not
us our fans
i would never bring this up
no no of course you wouldn't wait but
let's not skim over the fact that mom
you says that that is leaving comments
on pornhub videos he he leaves comments
he interacts and and exchanges points of
view with with of
his
the same as dating really
yeah exactly dating but you are married
i don't leave comments on any of that
stuff my only comments will be
politically related right won't find
anything other than that on there
because we can also check your tweets
and replies
unless as happens frequently people
blame hackers it must have been hackers
someone hacked my account and did this
if it comes out to more than four or
five
yeah obviously hackers that funnily
enough wasn't that the gabby hannah
defense yeah
who yeah okay so another thing we're
working on is that i gave my parents the
homework of exp look now that trisha's
gone there's this huge gabby hannah
drama going down
she is like been accusing everybody of
everything and i said listen mom now
that trish is not here i'm gonna need
you and dad to do some homework and come
on the show and explain
the gabby hannah drama
so how was your research on that
well
do you want me to give you a little back
story of what i learned absolutely okay
right i got to put on my glasses for
this my mom prepared a cheat sheet yes
oh you're much smarter now what i have
learned okay
is that originally
there's this
squad vlog squad a vlog squad
what is the vlog squad
well it's it's uh
vloggers that kind of group together
david dobrik has nothing really to do
with this director the boss this david
dobrik he's the boss of the vlog squad
right
and he's got a group of people that he
surrounds himself with and i guess each
one of them
vlog and it's like
it kind of reminds me of modern
housewives smashing into lord of the
flies
okay and
so it's like a beverly hills housewife
only one
only one wins you know it is kind of an
interesting
analogy isn't it lord of the flies well
i mean these kids are
like they've got a little bit of money
because they're
being viewed and you get money i mean
that listen that's why they're doing it
yeah and it's like following kids that
are in high school only these some of
these people are in their 30s oh yeah
and more jason nashville to see like 50
or some [ __ ]
yeah
it's just it just amazing me it and then
and then there's a whole group of
youtubers that follow these people
and they
explain to you what's going on right and
they make their
money and views on all the drama from
these people right and there's i have to
i have to call out on oh wait there's a
guy by the name of adam
mcintyre who's a cutie pie he's really
sweet okay i know who he is he's not
pewdiepie no no no no no i know who adam
is he is he's he's cute as a button well
let's throw a picture of
him i know who he is very nice young
irish lad my mom yes i think he's
adorable okay and he shut up from my mom
and he explains things and then there's
this other guy called rep zion
and he's kind of rep
yeah okay
and he
explains things and uh
you know
he's he's edgy oh he's edgy kind of yeah
i think so i like him so and so what did
you learn from watching that well i you
know i watched her and i watched the
drama and
i mean this girl gabby hannah yes
reminds me am i allowed to say whatever
the name say whatever
the the girl who must not be named he
can be named she reminds me so much of
trisha wow the two of them
are just two peas in a pod right this is
great i love hearing my mom describe
this because the two peas in the pot in
what ways are they similar would you say
drama lies
um fabrications
um
just causing problems
and setting people up basically
to make their lives miserable wow but
intriguing defense and there's a
sentence i thought i'd never be saying
i think gabby is worse because there was
a reality where she spread malicious
gossip about trisha based on something
someone told her and that became a fact
she said she said that trisha had std
she said she had herpes she had genital
herps right yeah
the infamous genital herpes rumor well
she kept calling it an incurable yeah
curable std which which is actually
makes it because like you're like she's
talking about like hiv right right right
she made it sound worse than that
doesn't mean fatal
right right so incurable std right you
know so i've got a i've got a uh
incurable std from uh well this is gonna
sound inseparable but i think it's funny
i've got an incurable scd from ela his
name's theodore
[Laughter]
i love him though so he's not a disease
just my angel he's the best he's my
angel anyway so i think that put uh uh
gabby
lower on the scale of lying about
nutrition
right
because they didn't even know each other
and you know that video was so old
tricia was even kind of thin back then
so oh my gosh
ouch
you can't see that what you just guessed
i guess that's the joy of having my dad
here
is he here say uh let's not unpack that
that's part of rising to her defense
okay so
this gabby how was saying that she used
to be skinny in her defense well that's
how long the drama's gone on that
you know gabby lied about trisha
way back then
when she was skinny when she was skinny
or thinner let's put it that way she she
was a little thinner wow
i guess you could say the same thing
about me if something happened a long
time ago that's true and many have
that my dad will be issuing an apology
next episode for these statements
i get vault
so now there's another person that gabby
this this gabby hannah has has ruined
well i don't know about ruined her life
but she really
you know
is a serious thing
oh yeah really serious and a lot of
women do not come forward because
one people
question if what they're saying is true
one is the trauma of actual the actual
act
you know and and
you know just trying to mend
it's really difficult
now
one of the things i will say about
uh about uh jessie smiles oh we're
introducing a new uh
a new character as in okay well she's so
jessie's smile she was
by this chris henson who was her
ex-boyfriend
it was her ex-boyfriend curtis i think
you're talking about the curtis curtis
hey it is courtesy and did you complete
account
uh
wow
let's just move on it must have been bad
look at dad's eyebrows look at his face
you can still go home and unfollow
before this
gets posted
why gary why
or you can just let it or let your freak
flag fly i'm fine with it yeah okay good
for you
support sex workers yes
uh you won't just tell us the number ian
that you stopped at
so ian stopped at around 11 and he just
snapped out oh
you said three
okay i was never good at counting yeah
right all right so anyway sorry so jesse
so you were talking about jesse smiles
and this guy curtis what's his last name
i thought it was i thought his name was
hanson but maybe i'm wrong we're talking
about chris henson
laporte oh you're right you're right i
don't know i i don't know i there were
so many characters that i had to look up
is that the host of to catch a predator
yeah cr that would be
chris hanson very close okay well
anyways she
well if we're accusing someone of let's
get their names right okay
yes you're right you're absolutely right
i'm so i'm so sorry to chris chris
whoever you are whoever you are not a
real person yeah
anyway uh
so
she she's been a part of this
vlog squad i believe
and
you know they they party and know what
no matter what they do they have their
phones handy
to to document everything it's it's
insane how they live
and i guess she got so drunk
and her ex-boyfriend while she was drunk
so we're talking about yes right he was
actually
uh he he was uh convicted of
felony assault so he was actually tried
and convicted yeah
yeah now what do you think about people
like keemstar who say
i don't believe she's telling the truth
because you can't
we say our word i guess because we get
dinged
well we use the sling like the young
kids we say r word oh so i can't say
that it's okay that you said it but say
our word r word
well you know but then what do you say
to people like keemstar who say she she
she's lying because you can't r word
your girlfriend
well that's not true you can get you can
get r
by your husband
right you can
i mean
you know
i think game star is just a low life who
will do anything to get clicks um he
knows no bottom yeah he and gabby would
make a good pair i think if they thought
about dating i think they would have a
wonderful relationship interesting
insight from dad
yeah well
she uh
this gabby
a hannah
who was supposedly friends although i
would say that word loosely
she went and
spilled her guts and said she didn't
believe that he had raped her friend
and so i think that the oh oops
the our world the word
and and so that was the whole the latest
drama so why didn't she believe her
supposedly she had a conversation with
this guy and who knows you know
this girl is is a piece she's she's a
piece of work
she really is i mean i watch some of her
videos she's very talented
like in what regard well she sings and
she
writes music and she dresses up and she
moves on camera and i think it's well
done yeah well i mean you know she's
it's not my taste but she is
talented i couldn't do what she does
sure so i beg to differ i think if your
heart was in it you could do that
and we could even try you have more
talent than her dad you are you a fan of
gabby's music
no
wow i tried to watch it you know and
dealing with this whole thing
i've lost at least 10 iq points having
to dig through all of this and i
couldn't help but think
the time that's wasted by all these
people dealing with nonsense you know
there's so many issues in the world that
are important
it's just
hours and hours and hours of people
talking about themselves
and it just so you're you're saying the
issue of if gabby and trisha were they
actually friends or not is it not
it's not an it is not something worth
following for hours per day
among other things yes
okay so
thank you for the clarification so back
to mom
so we
so we have gabby hannah
who is now gone against her friend
publicly i think she thinks she's lying
about being r-worded right well she's
she's recently apologized for it
but you know the damage was done and
this girl is really upset about the
whole deal that her friend would side
with this guy even talk to this guy
you know women like i said have to deal
with these issues and it's it's not fun
it's just not fun knowing the whole
world knows that you experience this and
it was her ex-boyfriend it wasn't her
her present boyfriend and who knows what
kind of drama transpired between the two
of them
you know that broke them up why do you
think um
gabby went against her friend to defend
this this uh r word you know i've been
trying to
get inside this girl's head okay i'm
glad she's thinking which is really
don't go there
to be
but uh
you know
she
she claims that she's got all these
mental issues
right which one she says she has adhd
right right right she doesn't
does that explain her behavior do you
think no
i don't think so i mean i'm not a
psychiatrist or psychologist but i don't
think so i just think that that is an
excuse
and
this girl
is just a drama queen when i went to
high school there were different groups
there were these snobby rich girls
you know that always wore really nice
clothes and were full of themselves and
and then there was groups that were just
you know your middle of the class girls
that were friends with with all of their
buddies
you know and then
whatever there's always different little
groups and and they were
clicks
and that's what this whole thing reminds
me of is
a click it's just high school drama it's
high school drama and some of the things
that comes out of that girl's mouth
i mean
what other things did i read about her
she i mean she went off on one of her
fans she had makeup
that she was promoting
and or brushes maybe it wasn't makeup it
was brushes
and i think she did it just for the
money and she promoted this product that
she probably never even a youtuber
promoting things for money yeah you know
unheard of and and so when her fans i
guess
uh
you know told her how they felt that it
was crap she said well what do you want
for 10 bucks
you know it's like what i haven't heard
about that one what
you know it was it's crazy we're
supposed to be free only pay the freight
yeah oh
which probably the freight was probably
a dollar so it was a shipping scheme
yeah it was a bait-and-see which type of
thing oh okay i didn't know she was sure
so that when there's a big question when
it comes to gabby hannah she's trying to
say trisha and i were like best friends
or really good friends and trisha's like
i don't know this girl well that's what
trisha says i think that there's you
know trisha
i mean
go ahead
speak your mind i think the girls knew
each other i don't know how friendly
they were but you know i think that
trisha was probably downplaying
her relationship with this girl
you know obviously they're not best of
friends they were more acquaintances but
she knew her
it's not like oh i have never heard of
her before i never i i don't you've read
the text messages
yeah there were i mean they they
interact with them yeah this is the best
drama summary ever
i want my mom i want you to explain all
youtube drama oh yeah yeah
oh and then what was the other thing
that somebody oh well she
claimed someone assaulted her but right
right cheese what's that they went to a
grilled cheese
rice gum rice yeah yeah yeah
it was some
[Applause]
oh that's so two words and a food in
there so yeah it was food rice gums got
to be known as grilled cheese now do you
like grilled cheese
okay so wait wait so you're saying trish
is downplaying the friendship but you
think gabby's up playing the friendship
with trisha yes there's some you know
there's the truth and then there's the
teacher they're both playing at it yeah
yeah yeah they both are
they just drop it why is it always gonna
be like who cares how close they were
you know what i mean because everyone's
gotta win but it's just so stupid like
who cares how close you were gab is like
we're best friends we're just like wait
i didn't know you at all it's like oh
get some [ __ ] well that's the whole
thing of their drama you know that's the
the can i hate your coke zero
can you what can i hit your code zero
hit it yeah yeah sure thank you is that
one of the words no oh okay
oh
oh
that was a broad moment right there a
bro it was not a brahmana was that a bra
you interrupted her to want to hit the
coke that's a bro moment oh well she she
was that's a bro moment but this is not
a bra moment
bruh don't even try okay the moment is
lost
oh your lipstick's all over it
i gotta like pour it in a cup well you
can wipe it off
i don't have cooties is that here hold
on one sec
so she went she went to
this party with all of these vlog uh
people
you know the squad or whatever
and this guy this rice
cheese okay this grilled cheese was
tired and jet lagged
and she said can i you know
have a you know can i
record you
and he oh that was the soda pop and he
said no please
don't put this let's not record this and
she kept on going on and on and pushing
him and pushing him and it's like he's
tired he's hungry
leave the guy alone but she just kept on
digging and digging and finally
he lost it got mad
and
whacked the phone out of her hand
the phone got broken
but she took it a step farther and said
that he
hit her
which he did not oh so we were defending
yeah today yeah and rice gum and they
even showed pictures of her knees when
she when it was being recorded that she
had bruises on her knees before
the you know she had actually hit the
phone out of her he was trying to claim
that he gave her the bruises on her yeah
she was like she he assaulted her yeah
but you can see in the video those
bruises were already there right i
realized it's a deep dive this is good
stuff and and the
guy who he was sitting here talking to
also responded to this and gave a very
apparently truthful version of what
happened when he just grabbed the phone
out of her hand and smashed it but i
think she was trying to set him up
initially because i guess he is well
known for rapping spontaneously
and she had accused him of of
you know like memorizing the wraps and
not doing it so she was trying to
embarrass him
by sticking the camera in his face and
it's right you know i don't want to do
that that's the breaking point you know
people would have done the same do you
believe that grilled cheese was
justified in breaking the phone
no no there's no justification for him
he didn't think that either he then
mowed her like two thousand dollars oh
he did yeah yeah he paid for the phone
well
more than it was worth okay you know
gabby
are you giving a shout out to ricegum
here now grilled cheese i'm on your side
where are we giving a shout out to him
yeah into the pot i believe no no he's
the enemy of the pod he's an enemy never
mind but no you think are we getting a
shout out i don't believe i don't like
the guy honestly not a shout out but it
was not
it what don't you like about him
i don't know he's just weird right he's
just really weird daddy you have a
takeaway i can't even understand him
he's just weird watch any of his videos
so i didn't really form an opinion on it
i couldn't understand a heck of being
the victim of false accusations so
you're team ricegum
give him a shout out dad don't be afraid
as opposed to team gabby undoubtedly yes
yes on god
on god yes on god correct on guard
and gabby when she first started i mean
she has a heck of a lot of nerve because
she used to steal jokes oh
from other
other wow oh a lot of nerve yep you know
something i read today i didn't know
apparently this one kid put together a
comp just like some random dude put
together a compilation of all the jokes
she stole and she was like trying to
threaten him oh she doxxed him did you
oh yeah oh she does that all the time
she'll she'll you know wait so what did
she claims videos and she
she unfriends you and
she's mean well and she had the same
lame excuse for every joke she stole
which was well this was a couple years
ago and i might have heard it and it
went into my subconscious and then i
said it later well i didn't remember
where it came from right but the thing
is on some of you do you buy that dad no
hell no
no because on some of her her uh vlogs
or videos she says oh yeah i'm really
familiar i follow these guys i think
they're great but then magically their
jokes appear exactly oh we don't like
that right i know bo burnham friend of
the pod yes bo is a friend of the pod
she had a joke stolen among others oh
yeah she had a weird did you guys see
how she was pretending that she was
dating beau for a while no oh you guys
didn't see that no
yeah we had so much time
apparently there's yeah there's more to
her than big dossier yeah i will say one
thing about
uh
gabby and trisha
that i kind of respect
and that is sometimes you see them on
the video and they're all dolled up and
they look very pretty yeah and then
sometimes you see them without any
makeup at all and they look like [ __ ]
but they're comfortable in their own
skin right to do that yeah i respect
that about trisha so
that's something i respect there you go
that's nice to say something nice can
you say something else nice about gabby
hannah
before we move on
uh
let me think
uh
god that's a hard one
[Music]
well i think someone called her the
worst person
in that they had me met in la and i just
wanted to point out she's not from here
oh from somewhere else and a friend gave
her a ride out here
and then she dissed him
and said he was a bad person for no
apparent reason after he drove her all
the way out here so she can go back to
the east coast wherever she comes from
we're kicking her out not ballet we
don't want gabby in l.a go back to where
you came from where you came from well
second generation native californian so
we are xenophobic against gabby hannah
no back to where you came from yeah
there's one there's one thing i can say
unheard in her defense yeah
just one little tiny thing okay and that
is although
you know i i wasn't there so i don't
know but she says that she has food
issues she said she's had an eating
disorder yes
well i know she has an eating disorder
but i think is it food issues like she's
got allergies
oh what what is it i think that's what
she said that she had allergies and like
when she did some movies or videos with
these guys they didn't provide proper
food and it was a long day
and as a person who has
celiac disease and all kinds of
food issues i have a lot of allergies
and i have to be extremely careful
that's why i'm so bloody skinny
is because of food issues and if you
don't provide your guests with proper
food
that's not you know that's not fair so
we're defending gabby
that we're talking about the the
yeah she made a bunch of movies
yeah youtube the youtube thing with joey
right
they killed off her character at the end
but she stayed for hours she she had a
valid
point there with the food but when it
came to other things with the script and
this isn't right and the customer
reminded me of trisha
telling you she wanted to say in
employees no no you don't get a say
you're you're working for them right her
costume and do a job if you don't like
it leave you know it's it's not up to
you to make those kinds of decisions hmm
and is there something you want to say
mom
well
you know i mean
there's a lot of movie stars dad and i
were just watching uh the making of some
of these these uh
um
superhero movies which they have to go
through with their makeup and it's so
uncomfortable but that's a part of the
job and you get paid for it and you just
suck it up and and do it because that's
part of the performance and she was
complaining about she didn't like the
costumes they didn't make her look good
they weren't comfortable it's like
you know what be happy that you were
asked to do it right suck it up very
true yeah it was karen gillan who plays
nebula who has to go through hours of
appliances on her face yeah it's
interesting so so in short you're saying
gabby's was a diva and a drama queen she
was a bit of a drama queen a diva and
she should just suck it up and go with
the flow and so we're we have to go to
ad break real fast but before we do is
there's something nice you want to say
about trisha here today since you've
said a few mean things about her
i was thinking of something
of in mental conditions i think
trisha is a pretty clear case of someone
who has
issues that she's dealing with uh
in terms of having legitimate
psychological issues where gabby seems
more like she's just playing it up for
the drama i don't think she has the same
issues that trish is dealing with
constantly
i think i don't okay that's my dad's
statement not mine i disavow that okay
i think
trisha
can i say what i really think ow please
everybody i think she's toxic
i think i think gabby is also toxic
i think it's hard for a woman in a man's
world
and i think that even
you know
you're gay you're straight a man is
still a man
and women always are second-class
citizens so i know that they have to
you know
they have
right but but there's a fine line
between
being assertive and being
strong and being
ridiculous
and childish and well he's just that's
not strong that's like no no that's just
being toxic that's just the b word
oh
my dad is getting canceled today boy
the b word what's wrong with that and
mom what do you mean by toxic just to
define that um
just saying things that aren't right
that aren't true for drama
being
purposefully
mean
and
um
well as usual think of words that would
you know that are appropriate britney
said it best just see her toxic video
that answers everything right there
burton said it best what i don't know
what that means all right they're just
contemptuous
they say things they say things that are
contemptuous
yes
they're just not nice are they b words
sometimes they act like it
that's a diplomatic answer i would never
say that about a woman
all right let's go to the ad break we'll
be right back
credit karma has always been there to
help you make better financial decisions
and now they want to help even more with
credit karma money spend account you can
be rewarded for good money habits who
doesn't want instant gratification if
you're looking for satisfaction there's
no need to wait with credit karma money
you can also win extra cash
reimbursements for debit purchases which
is kind of cool considering
usually debit cards don't have right
right right now like credit cards yeah
it's very clever and if you don't have a
credit card you don't want credit or you
don't qualify
right you get those debit card rewards
right and dad i know how you you are in
the matrix with those cards so you would
appreciate this more than anyone
let's be honest dad how many credit
cards do you have
be honest on me right now no in your
name be honest three oh stop it you're
like
for sure
yeah
wow wait has that come yet i think this
is yeah no it is i think when you first
get credit like you want to get as many
credit cards as you can right really
right now
once you're established i have really
good credit
so far
uh you know i just use one card cash
rewards card
and uh
why were you i remember you always
yelling at mom like you used the wrong
card what was that about right what card
was mom using that she shouldn't
well we
i'll change cards through the bank we
use sometimes if one card is offering
more cash back or we were using more
donna you're using the wrong car still
does that
well you know what with credit karma
money there's one card it's the debit
card and here's how it works credit
karma money is a brand new checking
account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases when
you use your credit karma money debit
card you can win daily instant karma
purchase reimbursements on items up to
five thousand dollars all you have to do
is pay with your credit card and if you
win you'll be notified on the spot and
your instant karma cash will be added
right back to your spend account credit
karma money has already given away over
3 million dollars in instant karma to
over 50 000 credit karma members and
counting open your fdic insured spending
account for free there's no minimum
balance required there's no overdraft
fees there's no there's there are free
withdrawals and a network of over 50 000
atms and from july 1st to july 23rd when
you make a purchase
you'll be automatically entered to win
one million dollars wow
that's nice that all of a sudden dad
donald you didn't use the right card you
got to be using the credit karma cash
card money card million dollars credit
karma money progress starts here right
now go to creditkarma.com win money to
open your free account and start winning
instant karma go to creditkarma.com one
money to sign up for free and start
winning instant karma that's credit
karma dot com slash win money instant
karma is uh sponsored by credit karma no
purchase necessary exclusions and terms
apply cu rules banking services provided
by mvp banking incorporated members fdic
maximum balance and transfer limits
applied
we all shop online and if you're not
doing it with honey you are not shopping
online right right mom that's absolutely
right you use honey i do have you saved
a bunch of money i i have saved money
it's incredible yeah i i it's great
honey i i compared to like my dad who
used to clip coupons every night just oh
yeah honey is that dad who just clips
coupons obsessively almost
embarrassingly to the but you don't but
it's not actually you don't have to be
embarrassed for your dad that spends all
night clipping coupons it's just an app
it's not a real person
and it's one of the things that pops up
on your computer you don't mind seeing
there you go
good point
uh how does honey work
well
basically they search the coupon codes
so you don't have to
honey is a free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
applies the best one
at uh that you find in your cart
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
and they range from tech gaming products
to
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery all you got to do
is go to your favorite site when you're
at checkout the honey button drops down
and all you have to do is click apply
coupons within a few seconds honey is in
the matrix
testing every coupon code that has ever
existed for this site and once it finds
the one that works
boom
you'll watch the price drop magically
this has happened to me so many times
you know i'm i'm shopping on the
internet i'm not even thinking about
discounts this happens to ela all the
time it's like you're buying jeans on
levi's or whatever this happens a lot on
fashion it's like boom 200 becomes 150.
you say 50 bucks from nothing you didn't
think about it no it's great
um it really is amazing
they've saved their 17 million members
over 2 billion wow
it's a lot of money a lot of money think
about that
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free money it
installs in a few seconds and a few
clicks and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
podcast
love that i would never recommend
something i don't use myself and this is
something that i do my whole family uses
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
week
that's a mistake it's families okay and
it says it at the bottom too i don't
know that's just the type of i'll just
read that line here uh
pick it up right now
get honey for free
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
families
that's joinhoney.com
families
okay so you wanted uh re you didn't
haven't used any of the golden words yet
in fact you haven't even attempted on
god okay so
no that wasn't used correctly but it
wasn't you have to use it in the context
it
okay so the words once again are bruh
moment okay
no cap wait what is no cap oh wait i
know what no cap is okay and on god on
god okay you got a hundred dollars for
each correct use really yep oh man okay
so you are highly motivated
and that's for mom only nobody can
divine them for their but dad will start
pointing yeah you got a lot of flack dad
last episode for pointing and despite my
explicit
instructions not the point i i wasn't
pointing i was just kind of directing
you were pointing some really funny
tweets that one uh someone tweeted at me
about no pointing and they had like 15
pointing emojis going different ways
which i thought was very clever and i
told that person clever but we don't
break the rules on this show
so yeah shame on you shame on you i had
it was behind my back and now i know
um how that so there mom i don't know if
you've seen this something i wanted to
show you real fast okay
um
let's see
this is a post i'll read it to you 720
points i find ethan's mom extremely
attractive and it's causing an
existential crisis i'm 24.
thoughts
existential crisis probably because he's
24 and and then
i know i don't know if you're
comfortable saying your age but you're
in your
i'm 65. 65. this year i'll be 66 in
october that's pretty wild i'm an old
boy so this 24 year old is freaking out
that he's finding you extremely
attractive
well i'm
peshaw
shaw yeah let's push sean like oh shucks
oh i've never heard the shot like shot
well see i'm 65 that's why you didn't oh
okay
p-s-a-h
i think
dad does this guy have a shot with mom
i hope not
well she got a lot of
jennifer aniston and diane
seemed to be the two well that makes
more sense diane keaton but jennifer
anderson very complimented
your fans are very sweet here's another
meme that came out i just want to get
your take on somebody found uh this is
regarding
ethan's mom 25 years ago so oh they
found a picture of me yeah this is from
25 years ago wow they said it would come
in discreet packaging
[Music]
you get it
oh no they said
what does it say they said it would come
in discreet packaging
i'll play it one more time for you here
mommy then you can try to unpack it
this is regarding a story you told in
the last episode they said it would come
in discreet packaging
did you happen to notice the shape of
the load being carried by the big truck
oh it was the shape of
the the thing that we were talking about
a massive dildo
massive dildo yeah the size it's about
100 foot dildo
yeah
that is embarrassing
ah
so
those are the two great memes came in
the last episode i hope you enjoyed that
okay so here's something fun we're going
to do since trisha hated this idea so
much the questions and answers the
advice segment i love that me too i
think it'd be fun i feel like you're in
a great position to give people advice
you've been around you're a wise lady
you've seen stuff you've done stuff so
we have family's advice segment here
today oh okay for the two of us to uh
give advice
um
number one
do we have we don't have any names of
the people these are from
well we could just say like first name
last initial or something
anyway that we don't have that now it's
called please help
hi ethan and donna i'm in a little
predicament i'm dating my stepdad
he and my mom just split
i'm not currently living with her so she
has no idea
i love him but something feels off
please help
so
her mom
was married to this man right they broke
up right she's dating this man right
first of all i do want so obviously
don't do that
when i was growing up oh we have a start
we got a story
when i was growing up i had a best
friend
her name was judy can i say her last
name or no
no i would not her name was judy
i would definitely not and she and i
would go to these your address maybe and
phone number while you're at it
she and i would go to these parties
together
and we made a pack at the very beginning
that we would never date each other's
ex-boyfriends or anything like that it's
just not a good idea sure and
one day her boyfriend broke up with her
and he asked me out
and i said
no you said hell no i said
hell no were you attracted to him
not really so is he good good question
right easy for you to say no really but
one time i was dating a guy
and we just we didn't really break up we
were just sort of dating he was his name
was tom
and phone number social security number
no but he he was really an attractive
young man and after we just kind of
broke up
he asked her out and she said
she said hell no
girl power you know it was just it was
just a pack that we made it's not a good
idea there are
you know i believe that there's someone
out there for you
and i don't know what the age difference
is between
but you know it's
to to go from the mother to the daughter
nah it's really not a good idea honey
well what does it say about
this guy first of all if you're looking
for a good partner
i'm taking this question seriously
because like there's obviously so much
wrong with it but i'm trying to unpack
it so you understand if you're willing
to date this guy
there's a lot there's a few variables i
don't know how long was he your stepdad
was he your step that's into our baby
that makes it even more fun that's true
what's your stepdad because they were
married for a few years as when you were
like
in your when you were like 18 to 20
different story right but it all boils
down to it's a horrible idea your mom's
gonna
it's just a horrible idea it's the pact
with your mom you don't need to make the
pact it's your mom it's your mind and
this guy is a piece of [ __ ] there's no
way this is a good dude no who's willing
to go
from the mom
that means he's been eyeballing you the
whole time you guys were together first
of all weird as [ __ ]
well he's looking at the mom and he's
seeing the mom when she was young in the
daughter
i think
and personally i think it's kind of sick
that the like you said it's just not and
he's being very manipulative with this
younger girl
well you might say this is kind of woody
allen-esque oh for sure yeah
it's hard to top the woody allen because
like the girl he's had the girl since
like birth
or like well i don't know how old she
was when they adopted her but it's it's
just
it's off but the guys will not only has
he been eyeballing you the whole time
he's with his mom
but also he's willing to
destroy your relationship with your mom
right
right
it's all bad it's all bad and depending
upon how many years are between them
it's kind of
kind of we don't know how old she is but
yeah there's a lot i mean i don't know
there's so many variables like you said
we just don't know the p word the p word
no
it's kind of funny to teach you the
ropes the reason we say it is because
we're trying to get i guess there's two
reasons one is like it triggers people
but okay the others that
youtube is okay they'd be like oh you
said the p word yellow
all right i'll behave myself it's okay
you're learning okay but it's okay it's
okay we're learning together so so in
summary horrible idea ditch the guy
you'll find mr right trust me you will
that ain't mr right that is mr wrong
right it's definitely
all wrong everything's wrong about that
it's bad news
all right that that's a that's a no-go
from much money these are really serious
questions hundred dollars how much how
are you doing zero she's got zero
dollars what i thought on god you can't
just say it you have to use it but i did
i just used it that's the truth right on
god no but you have to use it in a
sentence ah you just can't blurt it out
i have to use it in a sentence you have
to use it colloquially as the kids would
oh lord i'm not sure and have a bruh
moment and i'll have a bruh moment
all right next question
i am getting no action from the ladies
knowing that ethan was quite the ladies
man in high school according to his
lovely mother
what could i do to change
to get some female interaction
well
women are so much different than men in
that men are more visual if they see a
woman that they find attractive no
matter what her personality or her
intellect is
they will pursue her date her
you know and whatever happens after that
happens but the initial
uh
meeting you have to be charming you have
to be clever how can you be charming and
clever if you're not neither of those
things you have to be funny how can you
be funny charming all clever if you're
none of those things
um well
i don't know you could you could watch a
movie you can read a book you can you
can loosen up you can
you have that gene or you don't and as
i've said no
you know
it's kind of unfair because women in
dating are judged solely by
their looks generally speaking so you
know giving a respective number where a
man
who is
maybe a a six on a scale of looks if
he's charming and has a good sense of
humor
he can move up to an eight in terms of
relative scale and you know well if
you're not charming and you just don't
have that gene and you you can't figure
it out
the only thing i could say is just be
yourself
be kind i know girls like bad boys
but i ha i happen to know
a young lady who
she didn't particularly like this guy i
mean she liked him as a friend he was a
really good friend
and
he just would not he would not get out
of her life he was there for her
over and over and over again
he was persistent
well no he wasn't stalking but he was he
was just a good friend and after a while
you know she
so you're saying i appreciate it
and convert yes absolutely your advice
to these guys who are nor charming
funny or intelligent
is to friend zone yourself
until
she realized she has no better option
that's putting a negative spin on well i
mean i'm just trying i mean i'm not here
it doesn't sound okay here's my advice
you want my advice
i don't know go for a girl that's not as
attractive
she'll look up hold it down dude just
tone it down bro you got to date down no
that's not low where you're standing my
advice is this no i don't know
you got the wrong person you can look at
your life bro do you have a good job
okay oh many
do you have a good job it's not that
good women want someone who has money
it's that they want someone as their
[ __ ] together and it's not going to be
like dead weight in their life are you
motivated
do you take care of yourself ironic
coming from me but i'm just telling you
these are good tips
i wasn't always looking like this that's
good advice
stay mo
motivation and confidence
will take you a long way
if you're not charming or funny or what
if you don't see yourself as that way
just be confident in what you've got and
use it to the max that means working
hard
that means taking care of yourself that
means keeping your apartment clean
unlike me i'm just i know the good
things to do i didn't do them but i'm
saying i guess i rely too heavily on the
other uh you're charming yep you are
charming
how dare you you're so cute stop you're
so cute
and it's true that was really good
advice okay well well anyway
you gotta work what you with what you've
got okay
good just maximize everything you do
have and make sure that you're reaching
your potential because no no woman wants
to be with some [ __ ] schlub let's be
honest yeah women look for security they
want a guy who's motivated secure
and on top of his [ __ ] and that's and
that all comes together in form of
confidence which is in my opinion the
most important thing when looking to
date so hit the gym delete facebook and
uh what's the meme and buy some crypto
don't talk to girls about crypto that's
another rule
yeah
i'm just kidding
lost another 100 there donna
on god dad wants that money my dad is
like come on donna
you can't just throw it in all god i
know i know
okay so there we go there's your advice
get your [ __ ] together dude stop
you're a better bet
you're a better dear abby than me
well you know i i have some uh knowledge
in the area
yeah be nice is a good advice yeah but
i'm not sure i agree with the friend
zone thing no
you're not you don't want to hang around
like some pathetic little weasel her
whole life and she's not into you you
got to move on and get your [ __ ]
together on to the next thing good point
the friend zone is not the place to be
come on we gotta keep things moving okay
you gotta and that's so that's my advice
you gotta read the writing on the wall
if this girl's friend zoning you and
you're interested i'm not saying you
can't have female friends but if you're
looking for a relationship and you're in
the friend zone you gotta keep it moving
dude you gotta you gotta be like peace
and love i'm look i'm i'm trying to get
my [ __ ] together
one of the things in life
that gives us
the
one of the most important things in life
in my opinion is having a loving
fulfilling relationship that that
commits to the overall happiness and
contentness of life yeah so our pursuit
of that is important and you gotta just
keep things moving dude you gotta keep
it moving do not friend zone and i'm
saying hey there's nothing wrong i'm not
saying don't hate girls who friendzone
you there's nothing these girls they
want to interact with they don't want to
be mean they don't they like you as a
person so don't blame the girl for
friend zoning you you know don't hate
her she's she's a good person for
wanting to keep you in her life and
stuff i don't know how much she's
leading you on that's a whole different
topic that's like
issue to issue but like no hate to the
to the ladies she's she could be a very
great person but if you're like and be
upfront just say hey you know what i'm
interested in you romantically do you
share those feelings do we have a
potential
and and that's true that just be up
front dude because life is short and we
gotta keep [ __ ] moving she and girls
like that they'll be honest with you
she'll say you know what
she'll say either yes and then you say
great let's go on a date let's keep [ __ ]
moving or she'll say no i see you as a
friend and now you have clarity let's
not be mad at her guys let's be
gentlemen she's a great girl you're just
not her type let's [ __ ] move it on
guys come on that's very true you know
when i when i was dating when your
father came along i mean the young man
that i dated before him
went to stanford
and
and
and the guy before him i was always into
someone who was really smart
why'd you end up with dad then i'm
kidding i'm just kidding yeah you know
dad was at ucla and and and uh my mother
always used to say to me
look for someone who
has potential
and so
she married me anyway
despite all that she still ended up with
dad and he was handsome and funny and
all that so that so there you go keep it
moving guys come on
now all right um let's see if i can do
better
[ __ ] with the door open this is
interesting
hi ethan and ethan's lovely iconic
mother
wow well
that's nice iconic my mom keeps using
the restroom number one and two with the
door open and it's getting really on my
nerves ethan if your mom was using the
restroom with the door open what would
you do i need help asap i can't live
like this
if one mom was taking a dump with the
door open that would be a problem
we would have been having a problem
there would be something really wrong
with her you know i would just probably
what i would do is well i don't know
what your relationship is like with your
mom but first thing you can do is just
close the door
that it you know send the picture
you know what if
if any of my kids or
or dad
was
doing that you know like peeing with the
door open well
i don't care about pink but
but you know if he was
poop especially if there's people in the
house oh that i would say
that's like a sex crime i would say
close the door i would just come right
out yeah i don't know i'm missing some
details have you asked her to close the
door and she refuses have you tried
closing the door have you say mom i love
you but close the door there's too much
information i would be interested to
know i don't know what gender if it's a
girl or a guy i don't know if the gender
is not in here
sounds like a guy
no i they might be a girl nobody wants
to see their mom [ __ ] it could be an
eye less so i think i don't think girls
out there want to see their mom
i'm sorry i don't know it's hard to say
it might be a woman but the truth is
first of all you gotta talk to her i
think a polite way
of just
getting the point across is just like
mom let's not smell or i'm not smelling
your [ __ ] today close the door no you
don't say it like that well it's funny
at least no i just say mom you start out
just say mom peace and love
exactly mom i love you dearly but you
know
close the door when you're pooping what
if she says it's my [ __ ] house you
live here under my rules i will [ __ ]
with the door open and you will smell it
and you will like it what do you say
then
i'm moving out
yeah
what if you're 10.
go live with your father
well you did i don't know because his
mom wouldn't close the door
i don't know that's a that's weird we
need more details yeah it's true what
can i say tell your mom just close the
[ __ ] be honest and just
tell her it offends you i mean you don't
have to say mom you're offending me but
you say mom i love you but close the
door
so
okay this is one
i'm gonna get a little worked up over
the work husband have you heard about
this phenomenon work husband work wife
it's when people have supposed platonic
relationships
with um
the other gender or whatever if they're
gay i mean but like a supposed platonic
relationship
uh at work so you say
if i was like in office and i would say
i was friends with like someone named
ashley i would say oh she's my work wife
i mean
she's your partner in at work i mean you
spend a lot of time together you hang
out right right i don't like that term
at all oh it's it's a nightmare i don't
know
don't just say friend why do we have to
imply
just your associate this is my associate
this is my
associate you could say friend
associates a little bit standoffish
um
[Music]
all right someone i work with i i don't
know i yeah this is just a friend from
work well here let me read the message
okay my husband works with a woman who
refers to him as her work husband she
calls him at home and tells him how much
she misses him at work and she ends
every conversation with i love you and
he says i love you too whenever they
make plans she never even mentions me
even though she knows we're married and
we've met several times he says he
agrees with me and thinking that the way
she talks to him is inappropriate but he
doesn't change the way he talks to her
which is equally inappropriate should i
talk to her myself
no this is an issue with your husband
your husband is allowing the boundaries
to be blurred don't blame her it's all
solely on him he needs to stop that [ __ ]
now yep i absolutely agree with way over
the line way way over you know right and
this is true of like any cheating or
fidelity issues it's like let's don't
blame the person that they cheated with
right let you gotta place your anger
your disappointment your frustration in
the right place which is your
significant other who's [ __ ] up
because it's their job to place the
boundaries not the other person women
women have a tendency to
see another woman
and say it's your fault because because
women
i heard this expression a long time ago
women will look
at a guy a woman will look at him at a
man and say
you know who might be married or
whatever and say i want you
right
but a man will look
at a woman say who's dating his best
friend or something say i want a woman
like just like you wait let me let me
clarify this no that made sense did it
yeah
i mean the woman is saying i want the
man i want you
okay if he's in a relationship she's
thinking in her head i want you you're
the one i want but a man will say i want
someone like just like you
because they appreciate the person
that they have these feelings for but
they also
respect
the boundaries of
i can't have you you're taken but i want
someone just like you and women have a
terrible habit of doing they're saying
women blame other women for cheating
because because it's their fault because
they know she is putting her it's really
their fault though it's the significance
it is not it is not they're just
misplacing the blame they make it
difficult i think
okay
when my father and mother were much
younger
and my father is was really a
straight-up guy he never cheated or did
anything he was really a great father
husband
and he adored my mother
and
he was in a working relationship and he
had a secretary and this woman was a
single lady divorce
with a child and he would you know when
the child had birthdays and things like
that he was getting her presents and
doing things like that and i have a
feeling that she was attracted to my dad
and was you know supporting him kind of
and my mother saw this and she said to
my she didn't talk to the woman she said
to my father knock it off with the gifts
you're either married to me or you're
not yeah and it stopped
yeah and that's what you got to do yeah
that was good you can't blame the woman
even though she might be true because
when when he first of all accepts her
let's say
he enables her when she's making like
come to my child's birthday or he's
giving her gifts he's enabling her he's
encouraging her he if she knew that he
was not interested exactly that he was
not she didn't stand a chance if she was
saying that would be an on god moment
no it would not no
nice try though good try though
that would not be an on god
that was a really good try damn 50 bucks
but like if she's coming and saying like
uh
you know if she's making advances just
an example he goes oh you look so good
today you're so handsome instead of
being like oh you look beautiful too or
whatever and he's just like thanks it
doesn't right right he doesn't encourage
an invitation he's not encouraging to
get the signal immediately that this guy
is not open for shenanigans well if you
constantly get compliments by a woman
that's attractive
or vice versa you know you can't help
but be flattered
and
so
you know
it's just there's flirtations that
happen right and and guys like to be
especially
you know you've got a woman what is this
what are we doing oh i'm making an
accusation no you've got you've got
you've got a woman and a hus a man and a
wife and say the woman's pregnant and a
lot of times guys when a woman is
pregnant and she's feeling nauseous
she's feeling tired there's all kinds of
chemical
changes that are happening within her
body and she might not feel like you
know sexy sexy and want to get you know
down and
under the sheets and the husband's going
you know
i kind of missed that and here's this
woman at the office he's looking pretty
pretty fine
giving him compliments yeah you got to
be careful boys well i think intimacy
for some women
isn't for some wives it's not just sex
it's sharing anything with another woman
that you didn't share with your wife
sure so anything that is private among
you is kind of a violence there's
emotional cheating absolutely exactly
emotional which is what this whole work
has been wi-fi is like i don't need you
guys having a special relationship that
is a violation
you know the couple should be
the couple should be of uh
the lock box the couple is the it's the
vault yep there's no special
relationships outside the vault you can
have platonic friendships but this whole
work husband wife has been this is this
is we don't need ex we don't need extra
vaults there's no vaults outside the
vault you got one vault you keep
everything good in there you don't put
other good [ __ ] in other vaults that's
that's absolutely so and summery should
you talk to her [ __ ] no you need to tell
your husband what the [ __ ] is up yeah
and don't get involved with the other
girl it's not her issue and if he gets
defensive
look should she be going after a married
guy probably not but it's not but look
it the she's it's him he's the one that
enables it so you better tell your
husband what the [ __ ] is up dude that's
right that's what i'm saying you can
even play this clip for him
i'm so pr i'm so proud of you the punk
ass [ __ ] your husband i'm proud of you
ethan bro there's none of this work [ __ ]
going on in my life i'm proud of you on
god
no
yeah okay ding
you're leaning you're leaning a little
bit too much on this on god i will say
well because it's easy i think you have
the road thing is gonna be
tricky got the on god you have to move
on to either bro moment or what was the
other one
no cap okay well we haven't really had a
conversation that it could say no cap
you can work it in however you want okay
i'll try well we're going to order food
after this
oh yeah you guys got to stay for lunch
say hi to theodore okay well we'll
definitely say hello to you
wallace is um
[Music]
is by himself and dad closed the door
because of the air conditioning and so
wallace is going to have to pee yes you
close the doggy door to keep the ac no
he won't go through the dog door wallace
will never
all right all right all right i'll go
through the dog door before wallace will
i'd like to see that
okay so here's an interesting one i've
resorted to selling my feet pics to
support my family
wait wait say that i'm assuming it's a
it's a woman i have resorted to selling
pictures of my feet to support my family
really mm-hmm well that's like hands
there's there's hand models well these
are foot fists it's a fetish oh oh wiki
feet yeah feet popular fetish so she's
wow and she can make money off of this i
bet you can make money selling pics of
your feet
i'm sure there's i've got really nice
feet don't get started because there's
people out there that would pay top
dollar for that we'll be finding out
tonight if she can dad are you
comfortable with mom selling feed pics
i don't see any i don't have a problem
with that yeah there's a very good
problem with that oh
you guys can't
maybe she can knock you off number one
at wiki feet
i've been banned from looking feet what
yeah they banned me really you've got
really nice feet you've got i know i was
number one
yeah let me ask you this if somebody
reached out to you guys
and said i will pay you a thousand
dollars upfront cash
for a picture of donna's feet what would
you guys do done
mom what would you do i don't know i'd
have to look into it that sounds kind of
freaky but it is freaky it's very freaky
um
i mean
if anyone wants to sell their feet
pictures then
their family it's not like she's selling
her
you know don't say it there's sexual
it's underneath your body it's anonymous
yeah oh what if they're like okay what
if they're like donna
i want a picture of your feet but your
face has to also be in the picture
hmm
i i don't think i'd go for that you
better [ __ ] not yeah no no no you
guys understand how not okay that is
yeah
no i would not sell pictures of her feet
regardless can you guys just tell me if
you get an offer and i'll
i won't tell mike i'll bid all that bid
for the people all right
guarantee on feedback
i won't show my thing thank you
dad what about you you'd sell the
feedback oh he doesn't have nice feet
not like me oh but people like ugly feet
that's the thing about that oh well then
you they like pretty feet like ugly feet
dad's feeder
he never cuts his nails the right way
is that you're dead
no comment they're like weapons all
right let's get to let's give this
person some advice all right hello mr
and mrs klein i'm kind of in a bind i
just had a kid and don't have any family
or support
financial support to help me out my
husband step back from his job so it can
be at home but that has cut our overall
income i need to make more money for my
family but the only option i have is to
sell feed picks
uh what advice would you bestow to a
fellow foot soldier in order to entice
potential clients
uh what could i stand out so this person
is looking
to sell feed picks
and they're asking what advice i don't
know dude
you're asking me if you can sell feed
pics i say yeah go for it you're asking
me
how to give get better advice well i
don't i don't know
well i mean if she wants to make her
feet prettier she could get like a toe
ring or put polish
different kinds of polish i was thinking
like stomping mayonnaise and [ __ ] like
that
because people like that freaky [ __ ]
get like a tub of mayonnaise and stomp
in it
yeah maybe you could like grapes you
know making making grapes like foot raw
chicken raw chicken oh
that's gross what mukbang
what muffin mukbang what is that what is
that isn't that where you going oh you
stuck somebody just stomping your feet
instead oh let's not say orgy
yeah they say the o word it sounds too
close to like
i don't like what's happening over here
because you're saying like
you're saying mukbang you're saying orgy
sounds too close to [ __ ] and now i
picture you watching porn
just like that was quick that was quick
well that's just what's in my mind and i
don't like it no cap
that's a no-cap moment yeah no it's not
no it's not
no that's let's put the cap on
not the saying but
okay i have no help for you uh good luck
to you stomp on some i don't know check
the google i don't know but if it makes
if it feeds your family i say yeah go
for it
man dude i don't give a
[ __ ] hi ethan and mother bear i've been
watching your son's content since i was
a teenager and now that i'm a grown man
i am picked pitched with a difficult
task i've been with my girlfriend for
two and a half years and i really love
her i feel it's becoming time to ask the
big question how did you know that you
wanted to marry your partner and when
did you know the time was right thank
you guys very much i hope you guys have
a great day lots of love
you want to go first
well
ethan has
more than one video probably
describing how all this happened with
mom forcing rings upon him to well i
guess
i do i wanted to marry ela
uh
like
all of my relationships before ela
i knew were temporary i saw like it's
fun for now but i don't really see
myself being with this person forever
right
ela was the one person where i didn't
see
that temporariness and i didn't see like
oh well you know this thing's going to
expire and so for me
so for me
you know
uh it was pretty obvious to me
in that regard that elo was someone i
wanted to be with
um in
that in that way right and like the long
term so right
marriage
so um for me it was pretty it was uh
it was obvious
so so you when you met her from from the
very beginning no it's something that
you grew and you felt well me and ayla
didn't really start dating for a while
because we had like a flame right and
then we were like long terms but when
she came and lived with me
and we started like living together and
dating and stuff and actually be like
having a relationship right and it
seemed pretty obvious to me that uh
that we were gonna get married right
yeah and what about you
gary you guys were perfect for each
other well
you know after our first date
i went home and told my mom i've met the
woman i'm going to marry or the girl i'm
going to marry
and it took me a while to get around to
it and mom actually ended up popping the
questions yeah i asked dad i knew i knew
she was the right i did
why did you feel like he was never going
to do it no you know what we were young
we were very young
and
out of school
oh yeah
you know every night dad would take me
home and we would be at the door and we
would be saying good night and kissing
and holding on to each other and i hated
saying good night to dad
every time it was time to end the
evening and i just said you know what
just why don't you just marry me
and
to my surprise he said okay
and then that night we went to fred
fred's house member with riva and irv
and everybody and we told them we were
going to get married
and how long had you guys been dating
two years oh okay yeah yeah together for
a minute yeah
i didn't know at the moment that i
started dating dad that he was the one i
was going to marry
but
we weren't dating very long when i felt
like
this is the guy
i won her over yeah
yeah and and fortunately for me
just like now your mother's never
realized how beautiful she is which
worked to my advantage or she would look
for someone much much better than me
right so i was able to you know you get
all the feed pics you want yeah
you know the fact she was younger and
hadn't really you know been out there
that much although i started dating at a
young age well if you wanted to lock it
up why didn't you propose
you should have put a ring on it we were
young we were very young tendency of
procrastinating probably
so this guy's asking back to this guy's
question he says
uh
when was the time right
the specific time i mean that was
something i had i i wasn't sure about i
just knew i wanted to marry her i
wouldn't waste time i wouldn't wait you
know just just do it it doesn't matter
how you do it it doesn't need to be some
big old [ __ ] production where you
jump out of an airplane and like there's
horse either you land on horses and trot
through a river i mean there's too much
pressure on it it's just stupid it's
like the the gesture the commitments was
important i wouldn't wait for a perfect
moment just let them know what your
intentions are just say hey this is what
i want to do this is what you mean to me
you know the sooner the better because
marriage is a beautiful thing and you
guys should just jump into it if that's
what you want to do you know what
your father always makes this
i don't know where he heard it but he
always makes this comment that men want
and men don't want to know what's on tv
they want to know whether that's a sign
no joke okay
sorry hannah they want to know what else
is on tv and you know some guys it's
like they wait and they wait because
they
you know they i don't understand i don't
get that you know and it's like look at
if you're in love with this woman and
she is in love with you
get started with your life well look i
know a lot of people get married and um
they settle so to speak i think if a
guy's waiting and waiting waiting either
he's not he's not sure right if you're
not sure then then they should yeah then
you need to be upfront about that too
but if you're sure then i i just i don't
understand these just do it these guys
who have like committed don't be that
guy
if you love her she loves you just do it
life is too short you're gonna go around
and you're gonna be
20 years older and go wow what did i do
oh yeah it goes right quickly right
and and
it's just it's a wonderful thing if you
have a happy marriage it's a wonderful
thing well i agree it is
it's
one of the bedstones or bed stones
bedrocks of uh of a fulfilling life in
my opinion yes um some people disagree
though some people like being single
that's because they're not they're not
that's because they haven't found the
right person
i'm not i'm one single shame but they're
lying
listen some people like being single
what can you do
um
there's one more here uh these people
are wondering how does your how does
donna wipe
front to back or back to front
they're front to back
front
to back away from the genitals correct
that's you know technically the right
way for a for a woman yes disgusting
women are women women are internal um
horrible that's a weird question
imagination are the thing to imagine
you say women are eternal
women have in in
internal right right right
you know
so
how do i explain to my family that i'm
making extra money from drawing furry
porn don't explain keep that to yourself
don't tell anybody
why do you need to explain that to your
family are you like cruising around with
like
you know a ten thousand dollar stacks no
it's furry porn you're making a few
bucks on this side don't tell anyone you
can't explain that it won't make sense
you'll freak people i'm just being
honest don't try to explain that bro
just keep it to yourself it's your
secret hobby put it on a folder on your
hard drive that's like hidden that
people can't find you know folders and
folders and folders don't ever tell
anybody about for your furry porn thing
keep it doing it you know the chat is
good express yourself artistically don't
tell your family don't tell anybody
agreed
by the way dan how long we've been going
we have another segment here we've been
going for about an hour and 20 minutes
so should we try we have one more
segment planned the name the celeb
the generation
it's a it's a special game
we have celebrities from the
for you tonight for me to name
and we have celebrities from today
for you to name oh my goodness and if we
one of us messes it up the other person
can steal
you know what i'm terrible with names i
am terrible with names your father
should play this game she get a lifeline
yeah maybe a friend yeah give me a
lifeline yeah maybe you can get three
lifelines
okay so ian how do we do okay so i have
the gallery should i just click this ian
okay
and you'll keep score
i'm good so the first one's for me i'm
assuming and then the next one's for my
mom
okay
i know who this is oh that's
see
hold on hold on who is this i know it's
i know it's a sheen but is it a
martin sheen
that's correct i got it all right see i
i wasn't sure you got it it was a sheen
martin sheen
that's a young picture of him
all right mom ah
who is this
oh that's pewdiepie or pewdiepie
are we gonna accept pewdiepie which one
is a pie you get one you only get one
guess so what is it is it pewdiepie or
pewdiepie pewdiepie are we accepting
pewdiepie
you know he kind of says it like that
when he's like doing it in the cute
voice
well accepted what is it pewdiepie
pewdiepie pewdiepie pewdiepie pewdiepie
i don't know he eat debbie when he does
he's like little like bernie he alex
rebecca would
pass on pewdiepie just for the record
pot felix
oh dad even knows the first name flexing
a little bit
oh
people said i look like her this is cher
okay that's correct
you're already doing better than we
expected ethan good job thank you very
much
okay mom i don't know what comes next
for you
oh who are these guys i uh we're looking
for either first names or name of the
youtube channel i'm giving even giving
you a hint you know what i have no i
wait a minute the guy on the left
that is that david uh dubrick
no he's not it is not okay do you want
to talk about no idea who it is dad you
can't okay you can't hint if you know it
or not that's the thing do you want a
lifeline
do you think dad knows i don't think dad
you're getting such a cheater
you can't even face us my dad does this
story he goes i didn't think dad would
know that it's not pointing
you're gonna be escorted out of the
premise
you got to turn around i'm dead serious
so who is it i have no idea
i've known ann hicox and anthony padilla
they're good-looking guys but i have no
idea who they are well that's a
compliment from my mom
so is it 2-0 oh this is so easy for you
no we gave her the last come on
well you think okay
[Music]
his name is um oh come on
you know who that is you're just putting
on no no i swear to god like i know who
he is but i can't it's like that his
name is on the tip of my phone really
oh god what's his name something
do we have a time limit here
ten more seconds i know it but i can't
think i can't remember i can't recall it
ah
gotta guess you got like five seconds
throw something out there something
leather face
[Laughter]
sundance go ahead you can steal it yeah
it's robert redford
i remember that but i just i i haven't
thought about robert redford in such a
long time
oh my god butch cassidy and the sundance
kid
paul newman
captain america civil war i think he was
oh yeah he actually wasn't a marvel
movie i forgot about that little movies
yeah
uh yes that she stole all right
i didn't steal the p i didn't oh what so
i stole the smosh yeah so you should get
a point for that as well so what's the
score so we're even i think
yes
yeah i'm ah i'm winning right
yes no me no ethan's ahead by one all
right nice try dad cheater
oh this is for you mom
you know what i was just reading about
this guy
i'm gonna flip this table i was just
reading about don't you dare i don't
know he's turning around thank you dad
i'm gonna go for a lifeline okay dad do
you know that
i believe that's jeffrey starr yes
you're right
i feel like dad conveyed to mom that he
knew no because we were just we were
watching this way all confident no no no
we were watching the videos and he was
someone that was
you know of interest
do you guys have any thoughts on jeffree
star do you want to make any comments
about it i don't really know much about
him i didn't really look into his bio or
anything that
no yeah is it is it it is a hymn right
yes it's a guy okay i mean i know i
didn't know if he he's not yeah he's
just very unique looking i think right i
don't think he's identifies as oh he
identifies as a man yeah okay
okay this would be dude i swear to god
i'm gonna die i like i know who this is
oh my goodness this was the only one
that this was the only one that tripped
me up when uh
i know who i know it is too but i had an
ethan i just i i can't think of these
old [ __ ] names now i don't feel so bad
that i don't know you're you're uh no
but i know who these people are just
killing me
robert redford he's the rain man
yeah he played in rain man
and he's from risky business right
no one of those ones where the one yeah
where the wives are one of the old
ladies we're going to head on in kramer
oh you're thinking of um midnight
encountering
no he's not
the graduate yeah the graduate right
yeah that was like his first time i saw
him on tv
in the movies debut yeah it might have
been his dude bro i don't know i have no
[ __ ] i cannot all right
i think donna gets the steal dustin
hoffman
i knew it but i didn't so now we're
equal it's three to five i think this is
like i think these lifelines are not
necessary this is some
donna's actually i'm fighting the
lifeline
wow i'm cutting the lifelongs are done
oh you just don't want to lose well you
don't need it i can't i'm not getting
them all you're pulling jeffree star
it's out of control of the love no life
let's give ethan a lifeline
no no
no
all right who's this mom oh lord
i know his face but i have no idea
that's how i feel about all these old
[ __ ]
he's been looking for a long time i can
tell he doesn't know
he was a guest on the podcast
that's true markiplier okay
point for ethan oh you're not gonna
you're gonna you know
[ __ ] idea really really a little
stranger to me
can i say go ahead mary tyler moore yeah
i've heard the name but i don't know
i've never seen that one in my life oh i
feel so old no
i knew immediately who that did you yeah
what is your i know the name what's she
done what's her thing the mary tyler
moore show oh past never seen it van
dyke yeah
dick van who scarlet witch
how about which you watch that right
what the [ __ ] is the scarlet witch mary
poppins dick van dyke played
yeah i know who the the original uh
chimney guy and in the only time i ever
heard merely tyler moore is in adam
sandler's jewish hanukkah song
oh
okay
all right mom let's see
oh that's him that's definitely david uh
dubrick do we accept dubrick
no
well hold on that's not his name it's
not dubrick it's close david dobrik yes
yes that's right okay okay she got it
i wasn't gonna accept dubrick i just
wasn't going okay
oh this is john wayne yeah that's good
okay ethan got a point for john wayne
thank you who's this
oh i have no idea who that is dad don't
you say shh
i don't think dad knows either
you guys were just in the drama sphere
and he's kind of like the god of the
drama sphere
yeah that'd be shane dawson of course
also i knew that well good for you but
you your lifelines are dead
shane dawson also a podcast guest
what the [ __ ] is going on oh i'm so
sorry that i don't angle this situation
so badly i don't know
okay that's why that's why there you go
okay up next
this is uh oh that's easy
is this uh lady uh oh come on
barbra streisand yeah that's right i
almost didn't get it everyone knows babs
baths yeah
who's this mom you know oh he's he's uh
one of the brothers that's the drill
um
he's the older brother that just does
all the wrestling crap
um
okay lifeline because i know you'll know
there's no lifelines oh what yeah okay
bring back the lifeline dad who's this
jake paul paul that's fun he knows that
my dad is too connected with all the
drama jake paul i bet i oh
your brother well i shouldn't john
connery yeah
i named our son sean conrad that's a
little bit of a strap i gave you a i
gave you a hint
i knew who it was i mean i love you
named sean after sean conrad you like
him i was i was looking for a name and
and uh
you know he was named after one of your
aunts that passed away but
i wanted a name and sean connery was
just oh my god as i found out years
later i just thought oh sean i gotta
name my son sean
mom like sean connery you couldn't tell
all right no were there nine more nine
more calm down we have no more that was
oh
mom do you know who this is
wait you only have one lifeline left
you've used two now
i don't know i'm surprised after
everything yeah i don't know who this is
well it's be it's kind of a
a trick picture i don't think so well
careful careful there's something iconic
missing from it wait she has not called
on you okay
um
he's that guy that i know who he is and
he's if i'm correct he's not well-liked
okay i'm going to use my lifeline do you
know this is the last lifeline i think
that's a beardless kim star
kim starr no that's not kim's star can
we accept kim is it kim ken hold on hold
on hold on are we accepting kim star
you're so close ken starr we are not
accepting kim or handstand star kim no
no
ken k-e-e-m-s-t-a-r
keen star keen star we are not accepting
keemstar you spelled it correctly but
you're but you're no
why can't you pronounce it right then
yes
the disability don't make fun of me
okay okay gotta say it
keemstar yes that's correct i mean jesus
christ
all right you're out of lifeline you're
winning anyway so oh it's tied it's time
oh it is tied you can do it i know who
the [ __ ] this out oh we were just
talking about it yeah i know we were but
i still don't know who it is gary don't
say anything
oh
some douche what's up
harry grant yeah i don't know how that
is
oh you know that is wait this is for me
you think i don't know who will smith is
oh no that's that's for donald it's for
me and you just said his name and you
just yeah you just goofed it up it's
minus one point wait it is yeah that one
was for you like carrie grant will smith
was of course yeah this is a weird okay
all right because he's a youtuber okay
right of course
oh lord you'll never get this
you will never get this and she is one
she might be my favorite uh female
musician janice joplin or no no no take
it back
janice joplin i i miss you don't say
anything gary it's um she's the complete
opposite of janice jobs she's a musical
style should i give him a hit no i can't
give you a hand he's giving you hints no
just be quiet
so competitive
she's kate
no jump
yeah is that a real person
joplin
no that's joni mitchell okay bye great
joni mitchell oh you'll never get this
i recognize that person too
and i don't know his name
dad there's no lifeline so don't even
try
that would be you may go as filthy frank
joji or george miller
oh my
okay oh you're gonna know that's the two
people that we were we were just talking
about earlier so this is woody allen and
mia pharaoh no
uh yeah both of them right wait what the
[ __ ] did i say wrong that's not me a
pharaoh
can i answer and get a half a point or
something hold the phone this is woody
allen
yes and something feral no there's no
pharaoh and there are no pharaohs
why are you giving him a hand
why are you giving he's my son
i'm your wife don't you no no no no i
don't know who that lady is diane keaton
okay bye diane
get the point there no no no we'll go oh
that's the guy that's in the
i think technically and she gets the
point
i didn't get both that's the guy that's
in the vlog
squad and him and trisha
fight all the time
wow you've got the whole world that's
not real
what is that do you have a name james
charles
you're not in the game you just looked
at me and said who is that i look you're
not in the game there's no lifelines oh
that's my point that's life he wouldn't
have got dad turn off his mic then
it's my point
oh we you guys should be around when we
play risk
oh you need to this is richard pryor
yeah
oh oh there she is you better not get
this that's gabby
yeah good job
oh that's it so how did we end it so you
probably won
ethan eleven
donna 13.
what an upset
it happened by her scoring more points
than you
how did that happen i guess i got a lot
wronger in the middle there with all
these ads yeah
i thought you won but i thought i
thought i did too i know
all right well that's families
oh it's over already yeah so
we've got no more content that was fun
number two
yeah it was fun it was a good time it
was fun
well i hope you guys enjoyed
uh do not contact my mom for pictures
oh yeah please do this is my new my
should i stand up sure okay
[Applause]
and this by the way thank you for
bringing that up this is a teddy fresh
hoodie that's still available on the
website teddyfresh.com
that was fun it was it was a lot of fun
good job everybody holding it down good
job everyone yeah
ciao so i guess we'll be we'll debut in
episode three okay we'll see if the
people like it i know
well maybe i can give better advice next
time well you got a good advice smash
that like button
oh we're asking to smash like buttons
now we've stooped to that level are we
asking to subscribe as well
hit the bell and are we hitting the bell
hit the bell he'll hit the bell ding
thank you dad you're welcome ultimate
height man
um
so you will not be so and like i was
saying no feet pictures
peace and love peace and love that's not
what we said well
i won't be
i won't be showing my feet but that lady
or that no from you if people want to
purchase a few pictures from you with
peace and love no more feet pictures
thank you thank you on god
[Laughter]
i think she might have just got another
hundred bucks right there wait i say all
right at the buzzer
i'm gonna give it to you right at the
buzzer
no more on gods you have to have oh
i'm gonna give it to you i'm gonna give
it to you
so you're leaving with a cool 200
bonus today oh my goodness
it's pretty fat on god
that's a total bra moment
all right guys i hope you had fun i had
a lot of fun
and that we'll be back next week with
number three and until then um
just the regular stuff we're out here
doing our thing all right appreciate you
guys thanks guys
[Music]
me
[Applause]
you